You know what? If I told you there's a
master mineral your body's absolutely
desperate for. I mean, it needs it to
fight off disease, protect your DNA,
even run your metabolism. But your body
can't make a single atom of it on its
own. Well, that mineral is selenium. And
today, we're going to dive deep into why
it's so incredibly important for your
health. So, let's start with the biggest
threat to your health. One that's
happening inside you right this second,
but you can't see it or feel it. at
least not until the damage is already
done. We're talking about something
called oxidative stress. So, what in the
world is oxidative stress? Honestly, the
best way to think about it is like rust,
but on the inside of your body. It's
this constant, relentless attack on your
cells by these unstable things called
free radicals. And over time, that
rusting process leads to inflammation.
It speeds up aging, and it's at the root
of so many degenerative diseases. So,
how do we fight back against? Well, the
answer, our hero in this whole story, is
an essential trace mineral, and that is
selenium. Now, this isn't just any old
mineral. The source material actually
calls it the granddaddy of antioxidants.
I mean, think about that for a second.
That's a pretty big claim, and it's
because of the absolutely missionritical
role it plays in our body's defense
system. And here's the part that really
gets me. Your body cannot make this
stuff. Not a single bit. That means you
have to get it from your food or from a
supplement every single day just to stay
healthy. There is literally no other
way. Okay, so let's zoom way way in.
Let's get microscopic and see what
really makes selenium so incredibly
powerful. We're talking about its
cellular superpowers.
This number is just it's mind-blowing.
Okay, so your body makes its own amazing
antioxidant called glutathione. Think of
it as your internal cleanup crew. Now,
normally one molecule of glutathione
zaps one bad guy, one free radical, and
poof, it's used up. But when selenium is
in the picture, that same single
molecule can be recycled and reused up
to a thousand times. That's a huge force
multiplier for your body's internal
army. And look at this, it's not a
onetrick pony. Not at all. It literally
forms these metallic fingers that hold
your DNA together to protect it. It
supercharges your immune system's tea
cells, making them five times better at
killing invaders. It's absolutely vital
for your thyroid. And it even acts as a
natural antiviral. I mean, it's a true
multitasking superstar at the cellular
level. Okay, let's just focus on one of
those key jobs for a second, the
thyroid. So, your thyroid, right, it
makes a hormone called T4. But here's
the thing. T4 is mostly inactive. It's
kind of like a car with no keys.
Selenium is the key. You need these
selenium dependent enzymes to turn that
inactive T4 into the active T3 hormone.
And T3 is what actually runs your entire
metabolism. So no selenium, your
metabolic engine just can't get started.
All right, so we've seen what it does
inside a single cell. Pretty cool,
right? But what does that actually mean
for your overall health? Let's zoom back
out and look at the whole body benefits.
Now, this is just stunning. Large-scale
studies mentioned in the sources show
that supplementing with selenium can
seriously slash your cancer risk. We're
talking a 69% reduction for prostate
cancer, 64% for colurectal, and even a
39% reduction for lung cancer, even in
smokers. I mean, these are not small
numbers. This is a massive protective
effect. And then there's this. This is
one of those direct A tob connections
you don't see very often. There's a
condition called cardiomyopathy, which
is basically a wasting away of the heart
muscle. And you know what? The only
known cause is a selenium deficiency.
The sources even point out that those
tragic cases of sudden heart attacks in
young athletes, they can often be traced
right back to a lack of this mineral
that was just sweated out and never put
back in. And the list just keeps on
going. It protects pretty much
everything from your brain to your eyes.
It protects the myelin sheath, that's
the insulation on your nerves, which
makes it critical in protocols for
things like MS and Parkinson's. It's so
important for muscles that a deficiency
is actually the root cause of muscular
distrophe. It even helps prevent liver
damage, supports your pancreas, and
yeah, a lack of it is linked to
cataracts and macular degeneration.
Selenium's protective reach is truly
bodywide. But there is a catch, and it's
a big one. To unlock all these amazing
benefits, selenium can't do it alone. It
needs help. And that brings us to the
final crucial piece of this puzzle. Why
co-actors are absolutely key. So, the
big question is, does this master
mineral really work all by itself? The
answer is a definite no. And this is
where the actual science of putting a
supplement together becomes so
incredibly important. This slide just
nails the difference. See, if you take
an isolated mineral, it might not do you
much good at all. You could have poor
absorption. It could be way less
effective. But when you combine selenium
with its co-actors, its partners, you
make sure the mineral is metabolically
active. And all that means is that your
cells can actually grab onto it and use
it the way they're supposed to. So, who
are these partners that make Ultimate
Selenium so effective, it's like a
nutritional dream team. You've got
vitamin E, which works right alongside
selenium. They're a powerful antioxidant
duo that makes each other stronger. Then
there's chilated copper to help keep
your blood vessels elastic and healthy.
You got to have vitamin B6 because it's
required by the enzymes that switch
selenium on in the first place. And then
you have zinc for even more immune and
DNA support. See, it's a true team
effort. So, the main takeaway is this. A
complete formulation isn't just about
mixing a bunch of ingredients together.
It's about a thoughtful design created
for maximum therapeutic impact. It's
about making sure the master mineral can
actually do its master work. And that
kind of leaves us with one last big
thought, right? If just one essential
mineral can have such a profound impact
on nearly every single system in your
body, it really makes you wonder what
else might your body be missing.